luck made his first NFL appearance in
years when he showed up on Thursday
Night Football so what has he been up to
since he suddenly walked away from
football remember in 2019 Luck's
retirement shocked the NFL world he was
drained from the cycle of injuries pain
and Rehab when injury stole his joy for
the game he chose to walk away but he's
found his way back under Center sort of
luck returned to Stanford last fall to
get his master's degree one day while
sitting on his porch he couldn't help
but overhear The Echoes of the nearby
Pao Alto High School crowd during a
November playoff game suddenly luck had
that football itch again so he decided
to do something about it luck sent the
email to Palo Alto coach David dejano to
see if he can help the squad this caught
the coach so off guard he thought his
staff was pranking him but this was the
real deal so he let luck join the staff
for next season luck is mainly part-time
helping two days a week primarily on JV
but he's able to work with QBs on all
levels sharing his wealth and football
knowledge to the youth it's really dope
seeing how he's giving back to the game
and seeing how far he can go being coach
luck